وعوده الى الحديده الى سمير النمري سمير
كنت تتحدث عن ان هذه المنطقه خلفك هي التي
تم استهدافها من القوات الامريكيه قبل نحو
ساعتين نعم بالفعل عثمان فهذه المنطقه هي
منطقه قياده البحريه اليمنيه وكانت قد
استهدفت في عده مرات عديده جدا وادى القصف
الى تدمير معظم منشات هذه المنطقه
العسكريه كان القصف بغاره واحده جويه او
بصاروخ واحد فقد دو انفجار كبير في هذه
المنطقه قبل نحو ساعتين ولم يعرف حتى الان
ما اذا كان غاره جويه او استهداف بصاروخ
بحري من قبل القوات الامريكيه المتواجده
في البحر الاحمر هذه التطورات عثمان تاتي
بعد ساعات فقط من اعلان جماعه انصار الله
عن هجوم او عدوان امريكي بريطاني استهدف
مناطق هنا في الحديده وكذلك ايضا محافظه
صعده شماليه اليمن بنحو 15 غار هذه
الغارات استهدفت مناطق في راس عيسى وهو
ميناء نفطي يقع شمال مدينه الحديده وكذلك
ايضا منطقه الزيديه في شمال المحافظه
وانفجار هائل كبير الان نحن الان انفجار
انفجار يمكنكم ان تشاهدوا هذا الانفجار
هذا الانفجار ل التو حدث الان ونحن على
الهواء هذا الانفجار يبدو انه استهداف
بالطيران الامريكي او بصاروخ نحن نشاهده
للتو عثمان ستشاهد هذا الدخان في للتو
سمعنا هذا الانفجار وانفجار كبير جدا هز
المنطقه هذه المنطقه هي منطقه ساحليه
ومنطقه سياحيه لطالما يستهدفها الزوار
لانها منطقه على البحر الاحمر تشاهد عثمان
هذا الدخان الان يتصاعد من هذه المنطقه
التي تم استهدافها للتو من قبل الطيران
الامريكي او البريطاني فدائما انصار الله
يقولون ان هذا الهجوم ياتي في مناطق قد
تكون معسكرات مخلاه اوقد تم اخلائها من
قبل ونحن نشاهد هذا الدخان يتصاعد بكثافه
من هذه المنطقه المستهدفه هذه المنطقه
كانت تمثل ا انفجار ثاني انفجار ثان ه
الله انفجار ضخم ضخم نحن نشاهد انفجار ضخم
جدا الان اقوى من الاول هذه هي منتقه
الكثيب الساحليه في مدينه الحديده عثمان
لا تصاعد الان الدخان بشكل كبير جدا في
المنطقه ويبدو انه استهداف بصواريخ ضخمه
جدا الانفجار هز معظم المنطقه العائلات
تخرج الان من من المساكن هي منطقه سكنيه
ومقتضى بالزوار وبسياق بالمواطنين ارج
يك سمير ارجو ان يكون الامر بعيدا عنكم
اعلم ان هذه المنطقه التي تقف انت فيها
بالتحديد استهدفت قبل
ساعتين فلا ادري يعني اذا كان تعد فقط
تبعد عثمان هي تبعد فقط امتار بسيطه جدا
من المنطقه التي نحن نتواجد فيها وهي
منطقه سكنيه مكتظه بالاف الزوار الاطفال
يتواجدون هنا بكثافه النساء لانها منطقه
سياحيه ويوا اليها معظم سكان مدينه
الحديده نشاهد هذه المنطقه لو تشاهد
المصور لسحابه الدخان الضخمه جدا في هذا
المكان نشاهد ايضا العائلات الاطفال نشاهد
هؤلاء الاطفال هم كان بالقرب من هذه
المنطقه وهم ياتوا للسياحه وزياره نشاهد
سحابه الدخان الم ف
اذكر الاث نعم دعني اذكر من انضم الينا
للتو ما حدث انني كنت اتحدث الى سمير عن
هجوم امريكي استهدف هذه المنطقه الكثيب في
الحديده قبل ساعتين ونحن على الهواء حدث
انفجار ضخم شاهدناه وبعده بلحظات كان هناك
انفجار
اكبر و وعلى بعد امتار نعم عثمان بالفعل
نشاهد هذه
السحابه نشاهد هذه السحابه الضخمه التي
كانت ناتجه عن صاروخين او غارتين استهدفت
هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه كما قلت كانت
بالسابق منطقه تضم قياده البحريه اليمنيه
وهي مؤسسات تابعه للبحريه اليمنيه ولكن
بالقرب منها وملاصق لها تماما تقع المنطقه
السياحيه لمدينه الحديده حيث ياتي او يقتض
بمئات او الاف الزوار بشكل يومي وخاصه في
هذه الاوقات من ساعات النهار حيث ياتي
المواطنين لتس للتنزه في هذه المنطقه
وكذلك ايضا للسباحه في هذا المكان وهو
مكان سياحي عثمان ومقتضى بالزوار والسياح
كانت القوات الامريكيه والبريطانيه بحسب
انصار الله قد استهدفت المنطقه قبل نحو
ساعتين بقاره جويه او قصف صاروخي نحن
بصراحه المنطقه اهتزت بالكامل في المنطقه
ونح نحن نبعد فقط مئات او عشرات الامتار
من هذه المنطقه التي اهتزت بالكامل بفعل
الانفجار الضخم الذي هز المنطقه وهو
انفجارين متتاليين استهدف هذه المنطقه
عثمان هذه الانفجارات التي حدثت للتو
وحدثت قبل ساعتين تاتي بعد ساعات فقط ايضا
من استهداف مماثل لمنطقه راس عيسى وكذلك
ايضا لمنطقه الزيديه هنا في محافظه
الحديده وكذلك ايضا استهدفت ايضا محافظه
صعده بنحو اربع غارات شماليه مدينه صعده
الحدوديه مع السعوديه مساء امس وكذلك ايضا
تاتي بعد يومين فقط عثمان من قيام القوات
الامريكيه والبريطانيه بشن نحو 48 غاره
جويه على عدد من المحافظات اليمنيه من
بينها صنعاء وتعز وكذلك البيضاء وحجه
وايضا صعده بس لكن ه هذا الانفجار الذي تم
للتو عثمان ياتي في منطقه مكتظه بالسكان
مكتظه بالاحياء السكنيه القريبه جدا من
هذه المنطقه سمير